thousands of Central American migrants
are vowing to continue their march to
the US border even though President
Trump wants to turn them away over the
weekend the migrants forced their way
into southern Mexico's surging past
police barricades and crossing a river
on makeshift rafts Mexican authorities
say more than 5,000 people including
women and children are in the caravan
most of them say they're fleeing poverty
and violence in Honduras it's a
hot-button topic for the president ahead
of the midterm elections he told a
weekend rally what he has in mind for
the caravan I will seal off the border
before they come into this country and
I'll bring out our military not our
reserves I'll bring out our military
Adriana Diaz is following the migrant
caravan she's in the southern Mexican
town of tapa Tula
Adriana good morning good morning I'm
going to speak in a low voice because as
you can see there are people sleeping
everywhere on the ground here in the
main square they're part of a caravan
organized by local advocacy groups in
Honduras caravans happen about once a
year leading people north and a large
group for their safety because it is so
dangerous to go alone or with smugglers
we saw people walking in 100-degree heat
they were sweating they were exhausted
but they're determined to reach the US
border roughly 1500 miles away on Sunday
the caravan lurched forward carrying
babies suitcases and hope in this
rushing river of migrants it was hard
for families to stay together
any song if nothing is who are these
girls we came across two sisters
separated from their parents she said
she was traveling with her mother and
her father now she's not with them and
she says her sister was taking care of
her this woman watching over the sisters
told us they were put on a truck by
their mother who then disappeared into
the crowd she says she has two kids also
she's not leaving them today we found
Karin Lanza looking for her son after
he'd fallen behind he eventually caught
up exhausted they've been walking for
ten days to get here most migrants cross
this river between Guatemala and Mexico
some entered legally through this
bottleneck
others out of desperation jumped
preferring to swim across the border
instead we saw federal police on standby
but they didn't stop illegal crossings
the migrants have finally reached the
city of Pappa Tula and it is now
starting to rain you can see everyone
trying to scramble for cover children
tried to make the best of the wet chaos
it's neither Davila sought shelter under
a tarp he's sixteen alone and has never
been to school there's no money
amid the crying babies and hastily made
meals we reconnected with Karen and her
exhausted children she told us she was
thinking about turning back she says her
kids have had to deal with being hungry
but they've never had to deal with being
cold having to sleep on the floor the
migrants next stop will be about 25
miles north to the city of tweet slap
every single person we've spoken to
tells us they are undeterred by the
president's vow to keep them from
entering the US as for those two lost
sisters we told you about we have
learned that they've been reunited with
their mother she apparently loaded them
onto a truck that drove away before she
could get on Nora
Wow Adriana I've been following your
reporting on Instagram all your videos
great reporting out there with your team
thank you so much